y vamos a las noticias de la salud con
más Romero salamaro Buen día para usted
gracias Ángela Buenos días y feliz día
mundial del medio ambiente para
celebrarlo pues hay que hablar del
impacto del plástico en la Salud si
vamos a hacer un repaso desde su
producción hasta su gestión de residuos
porque el plástico es tan omnipresente
en nuestra vida que los impactos sobre
la salud que tienen también son igual de
omnipresentes recordemos que es un
producto derivado del carbono o del
petróleo al que luego se le añade una
cantidad de materiales químicos
sintéticos para darle calidades como el
color o la transparencia
la resistencia la flexibilidad no lo que
sea que se necesita de ese producto en
ese sentido tiene también entonces todo
lo malo de la misma industria de
extracción de combustibles fósiles en
ese sentido porque se necesita extraer
estos materiales para luego poder
fabricar el plástico y pues por supuesto
el impacto que eso tiene sobre el medio
ambiente y la salud humana que ya
sabemos que aquí intentamos no
entenderlo como dos cosas separadas sino
que van de la mano recordemos también
hay mucho de los lugares de extracción
de estas Pues de estos minerales fósiles
también de la producción de plásticos
que se encuentran en países de ingresos
bajos o de ingresos medios y por lo
tanto todos los daños tanto ambientales
como es la sobre la salud suelen ser más
altos en estos países y en las
comunidades adyacentes a los lugares
donde sucede esto hemos hecho una lista
de las enfermedades que suelen tener una
prevalencia más alta en alrededor de
todo el sistema de producción de
plástico Empezando por la extracción de
Carbón o de petróleo eso está
relacionado lo quienes trabajan en este
tipo de industrias con más enfermedades
cardiovasculares con enfermedades
pulmonares como el EPOC la enfermedad
pulmonar de obstrucción Crónica o
también el cáncer de pulmón en la
elaboración del plástico que suele ser
cuando se manipulan todas estas
sustancias químicas agregadas y
sintéticas muchas además son
carcinógenas es decir que pueden
provocar cáncer ahí vemos por lo tanto
no eso más leucemia más cáncer de seno
también problemas de fertilidad ahora
veremos Por qué Y algo parecido sucede
con la manipulación del plástico en los
reciclajes no también hay más tasas de
neuropatía que es el daño neurológico
que puede impactar el movimiento o el
entumecimiento en las extremidades por
la exposición a este tipo de toxinas
Entonces digamos que desde el momento
cero de crear el plástico ya está
impactando la salud sobre todo de las
personas que hay alrededor de este
proceso Bueno hablemos entonces del
impacto que tiene en nuestra vida diaria
Sí todos usamos productos de plástico en
nuestro día a día o casi casi todos es
muy difícil no hacerlo sortearlo no y
estas sustancias químicas agregadas de
las que hablábamos se van a suelen irse
soltando en el uso y esto es lo que más
afecta a las personas que usamos
plástico en nuestra cotidianidad también
por supuesto por la contaminación de los
microplásticos que son estas partículas
minúsculas que se van desprendiendo del
plástico y que muchas veces por ejemplo
ingerimos o consumimos o terminamos
absorbiendo de alguna forma y aunque no
sabe exactamente qué impactos en la
salud todavía no lo sabemos puede tener
ahí el miedo por ejemplo de que se pueda
acumular en nuestros tejidos sabemos que
está en nuestra sangre pero no sabemos
cómo puede impactar a nuestros órganos
de estos químicos agregados de los que
hablábamos como comentábamos muchos son
cancerígenos entonces pueden provocar
más enfermedades de Cáncer y también son
disruptores endocrinos eso significa que
alteran el equilibrio hormonal de las
personas produciendo problemas Como por
ejemplo la infertilidad es interesante
aquí que la prevalencia suele ser más
alta de estas afectaciones en las
mujeres por ejemplo por cosas como el
uso de los productos de higiene personal
para el manejo de la menstruación pero
también muchas veces por estar a cargo
de la limpieza estar cerca de estos
productos plásticos tan relacionados con
la limpieza y hay otra población
especialmente vulnerable que son los
niños en este caso no que están además
por ejemplo desarrollando sus cerebros
no sus etapas cognitivas tempranas se
ven muy afectadas por algunos de los
químicos agregados al plástico buscamos
los datos de un estudio que muestra el
impacto de uno de estos componentes que
se llama oftallatos que se usan en
muchos de los plásticos que usamos
diariamente y vieron que las mujeres
cuando estaban embarazadas las mujeres
que más concentración de este componente
tenían sus hijos Al cabo de los años
tenían caídas o reducciones en el iq no
en el razonamiento por ejemplo
perceptivo o en la comprensión verbal y
también se sabe Además de eso que en
Casos particulares puede aumentar el
riesgo de autismo de trastorno de
deficiente atención Es decir que estamos
hablando realmente de una miríada de
impactos amplísima esa es una parte pero
también hay otras consecuencias que
tienen que ver con la acumulación de los
residuos mar si es la otra gran cara no
sabemos que estos plásticos tardan años
y años en degradarse por lo tanto se
acumulan muchas veces en el medio
ambiente eso impacta por supuesto el
ecosistema la vida Marina Pero hay un
ejemplo muy claro de cómo todo esto está
relacionado también con nuestra salud y
es para explicar eso Kenia hace unos
años investigadores de las universidades
kenianas se dieron cuenta de que todos
estos residuos esta basura de plásticos
que se acumula en las calles en los
caños en las orillas de las playas la
mayoría en comunidades además sin muchos
recursos para limpieza o para gestión de
residuos todo este lugar sirve de
hábitat perfecto para que se reproduzcan
los mosquitos que transmiten
enfermedades como el dengue o como el
chikungunya entre otros y que de hecho
ya se prevé que vayan a aumentar por el
cambio climático Así que como vemos todo
está relacionado esta basura esta
acumulación de residuos también puede
impactar muy fuertemente a enfermedades
de transmisión por vectores como los
mosquitos bueno impactantes además las
imágenes que nos trajo mal mucho
plástico termina incinerandose para
evitar que se acumule qué pasa con esto
claro no sabemos qué mal es peor no al
final entonces por eso muchas veces se
apela que se tiene que reducir el
plástico y no solo gestionar los
residuos porque sabemos eso que la mitad
suele ir a los basureros un 20%
aproximadamente es incinerario y menos
de un 10% se recicla y qué sucede cuando
se incinera Pues que la quema de este
plástico también impacta de manera muy
fuerte al medio ambiente
ensuciando el aire no aumentando la
polución del aire emitiéndose o dos
emitiendo partículas que pueden provocar
enfermedades respiratorias es lo mismo
que puede suceder no cuando hablamos de
la contaminación por culpa de los coches
es algo muy parecido y por eso además en
países de ingresos bajos se la quema de
estos residuos y el mal manejo de estos
residuos de plástico provoca entre
400.000 y un millón de muertes Entonces
esto según las cifras de un estudio
entonces pues en este sentido vemos Que
no hay una solución tan buena o más que
reducir de entrada todo el plástico que
producimos pues me alegro mucho porque
además esto es un gran preámbulo para el
tema que viene que es el invitado del
día muy amable escucharemos con mucha
atención